so
it's it's good to have you i guess my
first question would be
how is the the covet season been for
santa claus
well it has been uh very very difficult
for
myself and of course for those of your
listeners out there who
know what really goes on the many other
gentlemen with white beards who work
in all of the malls and shopping centers
and venues around the country uh
all of them are in fact around the world
uh all of them
are under various restraints and
restrictions this year
as to uh how much work they can do the
type of work they can do
and how we can interact with the
families
yeah i can only imagine that uh uh with
uh because
your uh your uh your model is seeing
kids your model is malls and if malls
are going through what they're going
through you're probably affected so
how has how has this affected you uh you
know from the standpoint of seeing kids
you know and and going to typical malls
have you guys had to adjust tremendously
well i think that uh as everyone has
adjusted
in their own lives in their homes and
everything
uh fortunately the internet and uh
skype and zoom have allowed more people
to communicate
and keep the face-to-face contacts going
and that is what a lot of santa's are
moving over to
there are a lot working in the malls in
the shopping center but
often they could be working behind
plexiglass or
socially distance where maybe the family
is on one side of the tree
and six feet away and the other side is
santa
and possibly they're all wearing masks
or maybe the santas are wearing the
the clear face shields i can't i can see
that you have to get creative at a
season like this so
if if you don't mind us going back a
little bit with you is
how did you become santa because i know
you you you got an interesting story of
how you became santa i think it's a
problem we just go there first
well i always love santa claus i am the
oldest of 11 children in a
lovely irish catholic family so we
always had christmas in santa
and in 1969 i was serving in the army i
was in vietnam
and a friend of mine when we came back
into the base camp on december 23rd
to get our mail and have an early
christmas dinner
he put on some shaving cream as a beard
and sat in a folding chair and all of
the rest of us
soldiers sat down on his lap and had
pictures taken to
sent home to our moms and dads um
after about 15 minutes that shaving
cream started melting and falling away
so i grabbed that can of barbasol and
put some shaving cream on and
sat in the chair and and with santa for
you know some of the soldiers in
our unit uh quite an experience
little did i know that a year later i
would be home going to college
working in a department store and they
came to me and said
um we know that you like broadcasting
and you were in the
high school theatrical group can you be
santa for a couple days
and thus started a career of wearing the
red suit
and how long has i been now since that
couple days well it's 51 years this year
holy moly
51 years ago not always with the
real beard for many years it was a
theatrical beard
but as we say in the industry as i teach
in my santa school
the number one rule is we are there for
the children
very cool and very cool so what what
is i mean to become a santa and i've
heard that you've trained i don't know
through your school some nearly 4 000
other santa so tell tell me a little bit
about
the business of being a santa claus well
uh
about 20 22 years ago when i started
doing the
professional center work and my starting
to retire and everything
many of the santas didn't know each
other there were been some going to
a school and there were a couple places
that did some training
one of them charles w howard school goes
back to 1938
um and it was once a year up in michigan
and um i had written a couple chapters
for
a book a friend who was writing and my
chapters were kind of like on
the work that we do the business that we
do
and the requirements we have and
somebody said that was good and i added
more and
all of a sudden i had a full-fledged
book and someone said you should teach
this
so i started in 2003 my own santa school
and i traveled around the country going
to different cities to where the santas
lived
teaching them and as of uh
last year 500 santas and mrs claus
had received diplomas from my school 4
500
santas have received a diploma from your
school
yes how intense is the school well the
basic school
is two days it's 16 hours it covers
everything starting at the beginning
from a little of the history
of santa claus from saint nicholas right
through to
uh present day uh you know a little bit
about uh
the different characters the media some
of the uh
some of the things that influence the
development of the santa
from the uh his travels you know he
started in turkey
uh st nicholas was from turkey and as
his
stories traveled from that area the
mediterranean up into europe and
then eventually uh to this new
continent over here to the us and
americas
um all of the different countries
influenced
the person of santa claus with different
customs and different cultures
and much of it melded together in new
york
uh in the uh you know
part of the 19th century and uh we we
ended up with santa claus in fact uh
the term santa claus first time in print
i believe
was in 1862 in the harpers weekly
1862 was the first time the term santa
claus was used
yeah well it had been used but in print
i know in 1862
i think that the dutch in new york had
sinterklas
and when the british took over uh new
amsterdam and renamed it new york
they required everybody to speak english
and sinterklaas
became santa claus so the name was
mentioned
but in print 1862. how much has changed
for you the season uh
uh you said you 50 something years you
said you've been doing this
how much has things changed over the
years of being santa claus during
christmas what have you noticed
um the big thing i've noticed is that
particularly in the last 20
25 years as the santas are
a little more stylish they do a little
more styling they more
more professional looking suits tailored
and of course back in the 1970s
you know the suit was nice but the belt
was usually a vinyl or
cloth with a little you know metal
buckle and
they didn't really have real boots they
had covers that covered their legs
oh you know so they wore street shoes
with the cover over them
uh as we moved into the uh the turn of
the century into
the you know into the 2000s and stuff
children are really smart
they can tell when something is not real
i mean
a child can watch a movie now and tell
you what cgi
so the thing is uh we have to have a
realistic suit so real belt and real
boots and uh and of course real beard
you know back in the 70s all the santas
and all the department stores
were theatrically bearded and today
rarely do you find a theatrically
bearded santa
if he is it's a high quality theatrical
beard it's one that you can
hardly tell you know but uh you know
today real bearded is
much much a necessity however i have to
clarify
you could put on a beard in a wig any of
your friends
ladies that you know could put on a
beard and wig and go into a little
daycare center with children five and
under
and if you got on a red suit and you've
got a white beard you're santa
so the magic still occurs even if you
don't have a real beard
[Music]
you